find the some negative 15 and 800 it's
plus negative 131 and fifty two
hundredths so let's just draw a number
line over here we draw a number line I
try to draw it as big so I don't have to
write it as small and let's put a zero
right over here and we're gonna start at
negative 15 and eight hundredths or
negative 15 point zero eight so that's
negative 15 and eight hundredths and to
that we're adding negative 131 and fifty
two hundredths so we're going to we're
adding a negative number so we're gonna
move this amount we're going to move
this amount to the left let me do that
in magenta we're going to that's not
magenta we're gonna move this amount to
the left so we're going to move negative
131 and fifty-two hundreds to the left
to give us our answer and we have to
figure out what that is now think about
the absolute value of this entire sum
think about it into absolute value it's
going to be the absolute value of 15 and
eight hundredths so it's going to be
this absolute value plus plus the
absolute value of negative one hundred
thirty one and fifty two hundred switch
is just one hundred thirty one and fifty
two hundredths so Plus this absolute
value right over here so Plus that
distance right over there but then of
course it's going to be a negative
number it's going to be a negative
number because obviously both of these
are negative we already started to the
left of zero and we're moving even more
to the left of zero so an easy way to
compute this is that this is going to be
the negative of the absolute value of
both of these numbers so we can view
this as we could view this as being
equal to the negative the negative of
the absolute value of negative fifteen
point 0:08 well that's just going to be
fifteen point oh eight and that's this
distance right over here plus the
absolute value of negative 131 and 5,200
swell that's just 131 and 5,200 so I got
rid of the negative sign so this
distance right here is the distance of
this magenta arrow over here so we have
the length of the blue arrow fifteen
point oh eight or fifteen and eight
hundredths plus the length of the
magenta arrow 131 and fifty two
hundredths
but of course the the final result we're
gonna have is negative if we didn't put
that negative there we would be adding
in the right direction the negative
tells us that our final result is going
to be the left of zero and we know it's
going to be we're starting negative and
we're making it even more negative but
when we write it this way it puts it in
terms that's pretty straightforward as
it's pretty straightforward for us to
compute so this is going to be so let me
just write this one hundred thirty one
and fifty two hundred and we want to
line up the decimal point let me let me
doing that same color so we want to add
one hundred that's not the same color we
want to add one hundred and thirty one
and fifty two hundredths to 15 and eight
hundredths and once again I've lined up
the decimal point so this is going to be
two plus eight is 10 carry the 1 or
regroup the one we could say 1 plus 5 is
6 we have the decimal point right over
here one point 5 1 plus 5 is 6 3 plus 1
is 4
bring down the 1 140 6.60 is this right
over here so that is 146 point 6 and 0
now our final answer is clearly not
going to be one hundred forty six point
six zero that's all the way to the right
that's a positive number it's going to
be to the left of it the absolute value
of our answer is going to be one hundred
forty six point six but clearly or 146
and six tenths or 60 hundredths but
clearly we are to the left so we are at
negative 146 and 60 hundredths or we
could write it as negative 146 and six
tenths